[Music]
overwhelmed with gratitude that is how
officer nicholas quintana tells us he
feels about the outpouring of community
support now we first shared his story
with you earlier this week the north las
vegas police officer and his wife took
in five children that he came across on
the scene of a homicide call well many
have reached out to us asking how they
can help the family the latest gesture
coming today from the owner of nevada
coin mart on jones and flamingo he
handed the officer a check and some cash
officer quintana says he is so
appreciative and is working to help the
kids move forward
right now the kids are
we're making sure that they receive the
help that they need professionally so
that way
they can continue with the grieving
process and continue moving forward in
their lives you know he admitted going
from a family of two to a family of
seven was a big adjustment
another group also offered the family
furniture along with clothing and food
quintana says he didn't do this for the
attention though he just wants to keep
those siblings together and happy